This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Today we have a story that will change the way you think about many things. Poverty, loneliness, time, even hunger. It's a tale about the psychological phenomenon of scarcity. It affects nearly everything in our lives and connects people who appear to have nothing in common. everything in our lives and connects people who appear to have nothing in common. The story of scarcity is a story of how not having enough of what you need can become the only thing that matters to you. That I think is the basic scarcity instinct. We're hungry and then this thing starts going off in the head saying,
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天我们要讲的故事将改变你对许多事物的看法。贫困、孤独、时间，甚至是饥饿。这是一个关于“稀缺”这一心理现象的故事。它影响着我们生活中的几乎一切，并将那些看似毫无共同点的人联系在一起。稀缺的故事，讲述的是当你所需要的东西不足时，它如何成为你唯一在意的事情。我认为这就是基本的稀缺本能。我们感到饥饿，然后大脑里就开始响起一个声音，说：
do you realize we're hungry? Have I mentioned we're hungry? We're hungry. This week on Hidden Brain, think deeply. We continue our annual summer series YouTube.com Authenticity is contagious I've been dragged into this all the way kicking and screaming ideas and advice about how you can respond to life's chaos Let me do it. Just check to my inbox. Just check, just check, just check to my phone real quick. With wisdom. This week, how we get in and out of the scarcity trap. My name is Brandy Drew.
你意识到我们饿了吗？我提过我们饿了吗？我们饿了。本周的《Hidden Brain》，深度思考。我们继续我们的年度夏季系列。YouTube.com 真实性具有感染力。我被拖进了这一切，又踢又叫，关于你如何应对生活混乱的想法和建议。让我来做吧。检查一下我的收件箱。检查一下，检查一下，快速检查一下我的手机。带着智慧。本周，我们如何陷入和走出稀缺陷阱。我的名字是布兰迪·德鲁。
I'm from Detroit, Michigan. Brandy Drew has a story that may sound familiar to you, a story of poverty and debt. It's the kind of story that may lead people to quick conclusions, so pay attention to your own. Brandy is now 37. Six years ago, her life unravelled. At the time, she ran the Dining Services Department at a senior living facility. She'd been with a company that ran it for more than a decade.
我来自密歇根州底特律。布兰迪·德鲁的故事你可能很熟悉，这是一个关于贫困和债务的故事。这类故事往往会让人草率下结论，所以请留意你自己的想法。布兰迪现在37岁。六年前，她的生活分崩离析。当时，她在一家老年生活设施管理餐饮服务部门。她在那家管理该设施的公司工作了十多年。
One day, she made a mistake. I was just in a rush to get home, that was all. Because daycare closes at six, I get off at five. It was like maybe a 10 mile drive busy traffic area. And I knew I had to pick up diapers and the easiest thing for me I thought would be to pick them up before I picked the baby up. So Brandi stopped at a store, ran in and grabbed the diapers. She swiped her credit card at the self-checkout station and raced out.
有一天，她犯了一个错误。我当时只是急着回家，仅此而已。因为托儿所六点关门，我五点下班。那大概有10英里远，交通很拥挤。我知道我得去买尿布，我想最简单的方法就是在接孩子之前先把尿布买好。于是布兰迪在一家商店停下，跑进去抓起尿布。她在自助结账台刷了信用卡，然后冲了出去。
It turns out she used the wrong card, not her own, but the company credit card. But it was crazy as I didn't realize at that moment, I didn't realize until my supervisor called me in and said, hey, what's this purchase? So has she not said anything? I don't think I would have realized that. Randy carried the card in case she needed to buy dining supplies for work. She'd never had a problem before, never been reprimanded. She thought an apology and an explanation would do. And her response was, well, you know we have to terminate you.
结果她用错了卡，不是她自己的，而是公司的信用卡。但这太疯狂了，我当时没意识到，直到我的主管把我叫进去说，嘿，这是什么消费？如果她没说什么呢？我想我可能根本不会意识到。布兰迪随身带着这张卡，以防需要为工作购买餐饮用品。她以前从未出过问题，也从未受过训斥。她以为道歉并解释一下就行了。而她的回应是，嗯，你知道我们必须解雇你。
And I'm like, no, I didn't know that. Like, can I just pay you back? It was only, what, 12 bucks? And she said, no, in cases like that, you automatically have to terminate the employee. I just cried. I cried for like a whole day because I couldn't believe it. I didn't want to go home and tell my kids what had happened.
我说，不，我不知道。我能还给你吗？才12美元而已，对吧？她说，不，在这种情况下，你必须自动解雇员工。我只是哭。我哭了一整天，因为我不敢相信。我不想回家告诉我的孩子们发生了什么。
I didn't want to tell my husband what had happened. I just didn't know what to do at that point. I felt like a failure as a parent because I didn't provide a good example even though it was a mistake. Brandy earned more than her husband so the loss of the job hit hard. She felt like a loser. She tried to bring in money doing odd jobs like cooking takeaway meals, but the stress grew. Brandy and her husband began fighting. She had supported him when he'd been laid off a few years earlier and she'd expected he'd do the same for her. But he felt a layoff was different. He was mad that she'd made his stupid mistake.
我不想告诉我的丈夫发生了什么。那一刻我只是不知道该怎么办。我觉得自己是个失败的家长，因为我没有树立好榜样，尽管那只是个错误。布兰迪的收入比她丈夫高，所以失业的打击很大。她觉得自己是个失败者。她试图通过做些零工，比如做外卖餐来赚钱，但压力越来越大。布兰迪和她丈夫开始吵架。几年前他被裁员时她曾支持过他，她以为他也会这样对她。但他觉得裁员是不一样的。他很生气她犯了这么愚蠢的错误。
The final argument was that I left out the house that morning. I was going to job interviews. I had two interviews that day, and I didn't purchase toilet paper. So when he got home from work that day, there was no toilet paper. When I came in with the kids, he just immediate started yelling. You can't keep yourself together. You can't do this, you can't do that, so I walked right back out the door and I never looked back.
最后的争吵是因为那天早上我出门了。我要去参加面试。那天我有两次面试，我没买卫生纸。所以当他那天下班回家时，没有卫生纸。当我带着孩子回来时，他立刻开始大喊大叫。你连自己都管不好。你这个做不了，那个做不了，所以我直接走出门，再也没有回头。
Without steady employment and a husband to help with bills, Brandy watched anxiously as her household supplies dwindled. She worried constantly about money. To make ends meet, she ordered a new credit card. The day it arrived, Grande tore open the envelope. She grabbed the card and ran out the door. I went straight to Walmart and I bought like a family size of toilet paper family size of laundry detergent. Like I stocked up on things all at once, whether than keeping it handy just in case.
没有了稳定的工作和丈夫分担账单，布兰迪焦虑地看着家里的物资逐渐减少。她不断地为钱发愁。为了维持生计，她申请了一张新信用卡。卡到那天，布兰迪撕开信封。她抓起卡跑出门。我直接去了沃尔玛，买了一大家庭装的卫生纸、一大家庭装的洗衣液。我一次性囤积了很多东西，而不是为了以防万一而留着钱。
So I like maxed it out within the first couple of days that I had it rather than holding on to it for emergency purposes. And in that moment, as she was maxing out the credit card on the household supply she needed, Brandy forgot about things that were slightly less pressing. What I didn't think about is what about gas money? I didn't consider what gas would cost. That was like the biggest thing. It was always hard to have gas. And of course, there was the credit card bill itself.
所以我拿到卡的前几天就把额度刷爆了，而不是把它留作应急之用。就在那一刻，当她刷爆信用卡购买所需的家庭用品时，布兰迪忘记了那些稍微没那么紧迫的事情。我没考虑到汽油费怎么办？我没考虑汽油要花多少钱。那是最重要的事情。加油总是很难。当然，还有信用卡账单本身。
The first two months I paid the minimum payment, and then I just stopped paying because I couldn't afford to pay. I didn't pay that card off until I got my tax refund the following year. By the time I paid it off it was over $800 for a $500 card. More and more Brandy felt trapped by death. She no longer had options. It came down to pay the bills or feed the kids. It was just overwhelming, trying to juggle all of those things
前两个月我付了最低还款额，然后我就停止支付了，因为我付不起。直到第二年拿到退税，我才还清那张卡。当我还清时，500美元的卡已经变成了800多美元。布兰迪越来越感到被债务困住。她不再有选择。归根结底要么付账单，要么给孩子买吃的。试图平衡所有这些事情真是让人不知所措，
and still maintain a certain state of mind so that my children wouldn't see me struggle. In retrospect, Brandy can see the mistakes she made. If she had made a budget for the whole month, she might have remembered she needed to account for gas. If she had focused on the big picture, she might not have maxed out a credit card she couldn't afford to pay back. Why did Brandy make these mistakes?
还要保持一种心态，让我的孩子们看不到我的挣扎。回想起来，布兰迪能看到她犯的错误。如果她为整个月做了预算，她可能就会记得需要预留汽油费。如果她关注大局，她可能就不会刷爆一张她还不起的信用卡。为什么布兰迪会犯这些错误？
It's easy to say she was being irresponsible. But here's the thing, she had always been careful and conscientious. Did something cause her to behave differently? When you have scarcity and it creates a scarcity mindset, it leads you to take certain behaviors, which in the short term, help you manage scarcity, but in the long term term only make matters worse.
说她不负责任很容易。但问题是，她一直都很谨慎认真。有什么东西导致她表现得不同了吗？当你处于稀缺状态并产生稀缺心态时，它会引导你采取某些行为，这些行为在短期内有助于你应对稀缺，但从长远来看只会让事情变得更糟。
When we come back, how the scarcity trap changes the way we think. Stay with us. After she lost her job, Brandy fell deeper and deeper into debt. One big reason is that she made a series of decisions that improved her life in the moment, but made it worse in the long run. She could have used the new credit card only for emergencies, but instead she maxed it out in a couple of days. To understand why she did this, I want to take you to a completely different time and place
回来后，我们将探讨稀缺陷阱如何改变我们的思维方式。请继续收听。失业后，布兰迪陷入了越来越深的债务中。一个主要原因是她做出了一系列在当下改善了生活，但从长远来看却让生活变得更糟的决定。她本可以将新信用卡仅用于紧急情况，但她却在几天内就刷爆了。为了理解她为什么这样做，我想带你去一个完全不同的时间和地点，
because it reveals something important about Grandi's story. It's 1944, World War II is nearing its end. Europe is on the verge of mass famine. Aid workers desperately need guidance on how to bring people back from the brink of starvation. Researchers of the University of Minnesota thought they could help. They launched a year-long experiment. As a 2002 documentary made by the University explains, the volunteers were conscientious objectors who still wanted to serve their country. The experiment? The volunteers had to go on a starvation diet. 36 young men, most of them Quakers, menonites, or Church of Brethren members, moved into
因为它揭示了布兰迪故事中重要的一点。那是1944年，第二次世界大战即将结束。欧洲处于大规模饥荒的边缘。援助人员迫切需要指导，以帮助人们从饥饿的边缘拉回来。明尼苏达大学的研究人员认为他们可以提供帮助。他们发起了一项为期一年的实验。正如大学制作的一部2002年的纪录片所解释的那样，志愿者们是那些仍然想为国家服务但拒绝服兵役的人。实验是什么？志愿者们必须进行饥饿饮食。36名年轻人，大多数是贵格会、门诺派或弟兄会成员，搬进了
the South Tower of the memorial stadium, which would be their home for a year. Many took courses at the university, even as they grew thinner and thinner. The young men became walking scarecrow. Some grew so weak in bony, they couldn't sit without cushions or raise their arms to wash their hair. I remember being a little bit critical of guys in early part who would lick their plates. I thought that was really pretty crude. Henry Schollberg was one of the volunteers.
纪念体育场的南塔，那里将是他们一年的家。许多人在大学里修课，即使他们变得越来越瘦。这些年轻人变成了行走的稻草人。有些人虚弱到骨瘦如柴，没有垫子就坐不住，或者抬不起胳膊洗头。我记得早期对那些舔盘子的人有点批评。我觉得那真的很粗鲁。亨利·肖尔伯格是志愿者之一。
He recalled the experience in the documentary. By the time we ran to about the second month of it, I was doing it myself. You just needed every single calorie you could get your hand on. The results of the starvation experiment were eventually published and remain an important academic reference on nutrition, famine, and eating disorders. But recently, two researchers became intrigued with the 70-year-old study for a completely different reason.
他在纪录片中回忆了这段经历。到了第二个月左右，我自己也开始那样做了。你只是需要你能弄到的每一卡路里。饥饿实验的结果最终被发表，并成为营养学、饥荒和饮食失调方面重要的学术参考。但最近，两位研究人员出于完全不同的原因对这项70年前的研究产生了兴趣。
They were interested in what the lack of food did, not to the body, but to the mind. I think this type of scarcity is almost like an alarm that goes off in the head, that's saying, hey, we really need this thing addressed. We really need this thing addressed. This is Sandal Molineathan, a professor of computation and behavioral science at the University of Chicago. He and a colleague, Eldar Schaffer, a psychology professor at Princeton, had a theory brewing. It went like this, when you feel that something important is missing in your life, your brain starts to focus on that missing thing. When you're really desperate for something,
他们感兴趣的是食物匮乏对人的影响，不是对身体，而是对大脑。我认为这种稀缺就像大脑中响起的一个警报，说，嘿，我们真的需要解决这个问题。我们真的需要解决这个问题。这是芝加哥大学计算与行为科学教授桑德尔·穆莱纳森。他和同事，普林斯顿大学心理学教授埃尔达·沙菲尔，有一个酝酿中的理论。它是这样的：当你感到生活中缺少重要的东西时，你的大脑就开始专注于那个缺失的东西。当你非常渴望某样东西时，
you can focus on it so obsessively, there's no room for anything else. The researchers were just beginning to explore their hypothesis when a colleague mentioned the long ago Minnesota starvation experiment. Elder remembers being immediately fascinated by the study and how the lack of food affected the minds of the men. They basically were very hungry and couldn't stop thinking about eating. In some sense, you would think, given that they cannot eat, that they'd rather be distracted with other things, but in fact, both subconsciously, the level of immediate reaction and their
你可以痴迷地专注于它，以至于没有空间容纳其他任何东西。研究人员刚开始探索他们的假设时，一位同事提到了很久以前的明尼苏达饥饿实验。埃尔达记得立刻被这项研究迷住了，以及食物匮乏如何影响了这些人的思想。他们基本上非常饥饿，无法停止思考吃东西。从某种意义上说，你会认为，既然他们不能吃东西，他们宁愿被其他事情分散注意力，但事实上，无论是潜意识里，即时反应的层面，还是他们的
choice of conversation largely was around food. It was actually a sort of tragic comic. I mean, they planned to open restaurants, to become restaurateurs, these memorized recipes, they compared food prices at different newspapers, that's what they were doing the whole time they sat around looking at food related issues. Even intentional diversions didn't work. Hunger and food had captured their minds. At some point the experimenters just felt soar for them and decided to distract them with a movie, and some of the testimonials were, they showed me this movie, I couldn't care less about
谈话选择，很大程度上都围绕着食物。这实际上是一种悲喜剧。我的意思是，他们计划开餐馆，成为餐馆老板，这些人背诵食谱，他们在不同的报纸上比较食品价格，这就是他们整天坐着研究与食物相关的问题时所做的事情。即使是刻意的转移注意力也不起作用。饥饿和食物占据了他们的思想。在某个时刻，实验者只是为他们感到难过，并决定用电影分散他们的注意力，一些证词是，他们给我看了这部电影，我一点也不关心
the love scenes I wanted to see the meals. Eldar suddenly realized he had seen the same kind of behavior in a completely different setting. He'd done a lot of research on the effects of poverty, and he knew poor people who sometimes behaved like the starving men in Minnesota. The poor people who were lacking financial resources found it very hard to think about anything but money, or at least spend a lot of the cognitive resources,
爱情场景，我想看的是饭菜。埃尔达突然意识到他在一个完全不同的环境中见过同样的行为。他做了很多关于贫困影响的研究，他认识的穷人有时表现得就像明尼苏达那些挨饿的人一样。那些缺乏经济资源的穷人发现很难思考除了钱以外的任何事情，或者至少花费了大量的认知资源，
a lot of their attention on financial juggling. If starvation made people obsess over food, poverty made people obsess over how they were going to make ends meet, how to make it to next week. What's in common in both cases is your head is busy with the thing you don't have enough of. The two researchers felt they were on to something. Maybe they thought the human brain is wired to respond to scarcity by tunneling in on
大量的注意力在财务周转上。如果饥饿让人痴迷于食物，贫困就让人痴迷于如何维持生计，如何熬到下周。两者共同点在于你的大脑被你所缺乏的东西占据了。两位研究人员觉得他们发现了什么。也许他们认为人类大脑的构造就是通过锁定
the thing that's missing. Sandel says this makes sense from an evolutionary perspective. Picture that you have somebody from 25,000 years ago who's basically a hunter gatherer, and who might need to do a variety of things such as get water, dover, a lot of resources are needed. When they get hungry, the sort of the evolutionary system wants to have an alarm that says,
缺失的东西来应对稀缺。桑德尔说，从进化的角度来看，这是有道理的。想象一下，你有一个25000年前的人，他基本上是一个狩猎采集者，可能需要做各种各样的事情，比如获取水、食物，需要很多资源。当他们感到饥饿时，进化系统想要有一个警报，说，
hey, really focus on getting food into the system. And that, I think, is the basic scarcity instinct. We're hungry. And then this thing starts going off in the head saying, do you realize we're hungry? Have I mentioned we're hungry? We're hungry. And it just keeps calling out to you.
嘿，真正专注于把食物弄进系统里。我认为，这就是基本的稀缺本能。我们饿了。然后大脑里就开始响起一个声音，说：你意识到我们饿了吗？我提过我们饿了吗？我们饿了。它只是不断地向你呼喊。
For Brandi Drew, the alarm might have sounded like this. You don't have the necessities your family needs. You need to stock up. Stock up now. You need these things. And when she bought the bleach, the family sized pack of toilet paper, the snacks and juice boxes for the kids, the alarm temporarily went silent. I felt relieved that those things, the small things I didn't have to worry about.
对于布兰迪·德鲁来说，警报声可能听起来像这样。你没有家庭所需的必需品。你需要囤货。现在就囤货。你需要这些东西。当她买了漂白剂、家庭装卫生纸、给孩子们的零食和果汁盒时，警报暂时停止了。我感到如释重负，那些小事我不用再担心了。
But the reprieve from the alarm came at a huge cost. But then like I said, two days later it's like, okay, wait a minute, why didn't you save at least $100 for gas? The answer to that question, Sendele Nellar, believe, has to do with what scarcity did to Brandy. She was so focused on getting the basic necessities that she didn't have the mental capacity to attend to anything else. There's a technical term for this. It's called bandwidth. If you're downloading a
但警报的暂时缓解付出了巨大的代价。但就像我说的，两天后，就像是，好吧，等一下，你为什么不至少存100美元作为汽油费？桑德尔和埃尔达认为，这个问题的答案与稀缺对布兰迪的影响有关。她太专注于获取基本必需品，以至于没有足够的心理容量去关注其他任何事情。这有一个专业术语。它被称为带宽。如果你正在下载一个
movie on your home Wi-Fi network, you might find your email runs a little slower. The movie is hogging all the available bandwidth. Send the LNLDR, say our minds, work exactly the same way. If your mind is consumed with thoughts about something, there isn't room to think about other stuff. Scarcity fills the mind with intrusive thoughts about what you do not have. It doesn't leave room for anything else. LDR says there's a simple way to demonstrate this. Imagine trying to hold an 8 digit number in your head. And if I simply ask you to keep in mind, you know, 26717164, that just leaves you less able to attend to other stuff. You eat less well, you pay attention
电影在你的家庭Wi-Fi网络上，你可能会发现你的电子邮件运行得慢一点。电影占用了所有可用的带宽。桑德尔和埃尔达说，我们的大脑工作方式完全一样。如果你的大脑被关于某件事的想法所占据，就没有空间去思考其他事情了。稀缺用关于你所没有的东西的侵入性想法填满了大脑。它没有留下任何空间给其他事情。埃尔达说，有一个简单的方法可以证明这一点。想象一下试图在脑子里记住一个8位数的数字。如果我只是要求你记住，你知道，26717164，这只会让你更难去关注其他事情。你吃得不好，你关注
to less things, etc. As you're saying that 8 digit now and now I didn't hear the rest of the next two sentences because I'm trying to remember that. I want test your promise. But in a sense that's kind of the metaphor. So when you're busy juggling your resources worrying about how I'm going to pay for dinner and if I pay for dinner, I will not be able to have money if the kids school trip. It's that keeping an a digit number in your head. There's a reason our minds work this way.
的事情更少，等等。当你念那个8位数时，我没听到后面两句话的其余部分，因为我正试图记住那个。我想测试你的承诺。但从某种意义上说，这是一种隐喻。所以当你忙于周转你的资源，担心我怎么付晚餐钱，如果我付了晚餐钱，我就没钱给孩子学校旅行了。这就是在脑子里保持一个8位数的数字。我们的大脑这样工作是有原因的。
Tunneling into something makes you focus on it. Everything inside the tunnel becomes crystal clear. The problem is, you can't see anything outside the tunnel. People in the poverty tunnel are actually very good at figuring out how to stretch the money they have to make it a tomorrow or the next week. Studies show that the poor tend to be better than the rich at knowing where you can find the best deals, the cheap tube of toothpaste. Someone who is poor is often consumed with finding solutions to immediate problems. How do I get food on the table today?
锁定某件事会让你专注于它。隧道内的一切都变得清晰可见。问题是，你看不到隧道外面的任何东西。处于贫困隧道中的人实际上非常擅长想办法利用他们拥有的钱来维持到明天或下周。研究表明，穷人往往比富人更擅长知道在哪里可以找到最优惠的价格，便宜的牙膏。穷人往往被寻找解决眼前问题的方案所消耗。我今天怎么才能把食物摆上桌？
I'm not thinking about problems that are a few weeks away, like the utility bill, or gas money, or a credit card payment. As you're checking the prices and remembering the prices and figuring out if you buy two carrots, you have enough money for breakfast, you are forgetting things you're paying less attention to, your rent, your kids' homework, all the other things that make your life complete. The thing is, as a result of doing this, the underlying problem can become worse. If you don't pay your bills, you'll be even deeper in the hole next month. worse. If you don't pay your bills, you'll be even deeper in the hole next month. Scarcity, in other words, is a trap. The scarcity trap for us is all those ways in which scarcity today, bigots behaviors, which leads to even further scarcity
我没在想几周后的问题，比如水电费、汽油费或信用卡还款。当你检查价格、记住价格并计算如果你买两个胡萝卜，你是否有足够的钱吃早餐时，你正在忘记一些事情，你对房租、孩子的作业、所有其他让你的生活完整的事情关注得更少了。问题是，由于这样做，潜在的问题可能会变得更糟。如果你不付账单，下个月你会陷得更深。换句话说，稀缺是一个陷阱。对我们来说，稀缺陷阱就是今天的所有稀缺行为，导致了明天更严重的稀缺。
tomorrow. And we think it's something that poor people do, busy people do, here's another example. We think to lonely do this, so people who are lonely will often engage in social interactions in a particular way which actually makes it harder for them to make friends. Just as the poor focus on the money they do not have, the lonely tend to focus on the friends they do not have. The result is they try too hard to be liked. In a conversation, the lonely person might be so preoccupied with making a good impression that he can't be attention to what's actually being said, the conversation falters.
我们认为这是穷人会做的事，忙碌的人会做的事，这里有另一个例子。我们认为孤独的人会这样做，所以孤独的人通常会以一种特定的方式进行社交互动，这实际上使他们更难交到朋友。正如穷人专注于他们没有的钱一样，孤独的人倾向于专注于他们没有的朋友。结果是他们太努力想被人喜欢。在谈话中，孤独的人可能太专注于给人留下好印象，以至于他无法关注实际在说什么，谈话就失败了。
Instead of appearing likeable, he's seen as awkward or flat-footed. What happens is a result? People avoid the awkward conversationalist, and the lonely person becomes even lonelier. This lens offers a new way of thinking about why people who find themselves in scarcity seem to do things that, to an outsider, looks stupid. When you're in a hole, why would you dig yourself even deeper? Sandal says we're asking the wrong question. What if it's not the poor people are somehow deficient, but the poverty makes everyone less capable? That it's
与其显得讨人喜欢，他被视为笨拙或反应迟钝。结果会发生什么？人们避开这个笨拙的谈话者，而孤独的人变得更加孤独。这个视角提供了一种新的方式来思考为什么那些发现自己处于稀缺状态的人似乎做了一些在外人看来很愚蠢的事情。当你掉进坑里时，为什么还要把自己挖得更深？桑德尔说我们问错了问题。如果不是穷人有什么缺陷，而是贫困让每个人都变得能力不足呢？如果
the... that it's you and I tomorrow where we become poor, what all of a sudden have the same effect. The poverty is in some sense changing our minds. How do we know this isn't some bleeding-hot theory to excuse irresponsible behavior? Andar and Sendal wanted to test their hypothesis. But if all this is true, one thing that ought to be true is the same person when they're poor should have very different cognitive capacity than when they're rich. So how would we test that? Well, unfortunately, we don't have the kind of money to go around making poor people rich, but sugar cane farmers actually create an actual experiment for us.
是……如果明天你我变得贫穷，难道不会突然产生同样的效果吗？贫困在某种意义上正在改变我们的思想。我们怎么知道这不是为了给不负责任的行为找借口的荒谬理论？埃尔达和桑德尔想测试他们的假设。但如果这一切都是真的，有一件事应该是真的：同一个人在贫穷时应该比富有的时候有非常不同的认知能力。那么我们该如何测试呢？不幸的是，我们没有那种钱去让穷人变富，但甘蔗农民实际上为我们创造了一个实际的实验。
Yes, sugar cane farmers, specifically those in India who are paid only once a year, right after the harvest. The month after they get that income, they're pretty rich. But like anybody who gets a huge windfall all at once, the money gets spent a little too fast. And so by the end of the harvest cycle, they're relatively poor. So now we have the same person, a month before harvest, poor and a month after harvest well off.
是的，甘蔗农民，特别是印度那些一年只领一次工资的农民，就在收获之后。他们拿到收入后的那个月，他们相当富有。但就像任何一次性获得巨额意外之财的人一样，钱花得有点太快了。所以到收获周期结束时，他们相对贫穷。所以现在我们有了同一个人，收获前一个月贫穷，收获后一个月富裕。
Again, you have the same group of people who are poor one moment and rich the next. Sendole Nelgar tested the farmers on their long-term thinking when they had no money and when they had plenty of money. The results were stunning. We found a huge difference. So we found that post-harvest when they're well off, they have much more impulse control. Farmers who were rich tended to think about things that would help them over the long-term. This matched other research that shows, for example, that farmers who are well-off
同样，你有一群人在一瞬间贫穷，下一瞬间富有。桑德尔和埃尔达测试了农民在没钱和有钱时的长期思维。结果令人震惊。我们发现了巨大的差异。所以我们发现收获后当他们富裕时，他们有更多的冲动控制力。富有的农民倾向于思考那些有助于他们长远发展的事情。这与其他研究相吻合，例如，富有的农民
tend to weed their fields more regularly than farmers who are poor. Farmers who are poor mostly focused on how to make it to next week, short term thinking. To be clear, it's not that poor people focus on immediate needs because that's all they want to think about. It's all they can think about. immediate needs because that's all they want to think about. It's all they can think about. Scarcity captures the mind, like it did with those starving men in Minnesota. In fact, scarcity can actually lower how you perform on an IQ test. Put simply, being poor is like having just pulled an all-linder.
往往比贫穷的农民更定期地给田地除草。贫穷的农民大多专注于如何熬到下周，短期思维。需要明确的是，并不是穷人专注于眼前的需求是因为那是他们唯一想思考的。而是他们只能思考这些。稀缺占据了大脑，就像明尼苏达那些挨饿的人一样。事实上，稀缺实际上会降低你在智商测试中的表现。简单地说，贫穷就像刚刚熬了个通宵。
Now, if you've been very lucky, maybe you've never experienced what it's like to be poor, or hungry, or lonely. But there might be another form of scarcity you have experienced. On some days we get to leave at 4pm some days we don't leave till 1am. So, and then you usually start the next day at 5.30 or 6am in the morning. Usually work 80 hours, this a week. When we come back, how being overworked and exhausted can produce a form of scarcity, too. And the pernicious effect this can have on your life.
现在，如果你非常幸运，也许你从未经历过贫穷、饥饿或孤独是什么感觉。但可能还有另一种你经历过的稀缺形式。有些日子我们下午4点就能走，有些日子我们直到凌晨1点才走。所以，然后你通常在第二天早上5点半或6点开始。通常每周工作80小时。回来后，我们将探讨过度劳累和精疲力竭如何产生一种稀缺形式。以及这对你生活可能产生的有害影响。
Stay with us. Eldar Shaffer and Sendel Moulinathan believe that when something you desperately need is in short supply, your brain tends to focus on that thing. This focus can be so intense that it impedes your ability to think about anything else. What happens when the thing you're missing is time. When you're so busy, it feels like you don't have time to breathe. Let me tell you the story of a young woman named Katie. She asked us to use her middle name for reasons that will be clear in a moment. For as long as she can remember, Katie has been driven, really driven. When I was in high school, I was determined to be
请继续收听。埃尔达·沙菲尔和桑德尔·穆莱纳森认为，当你迫切需要的东西供应不足时，你的大脑倾向于专注于那件事。这种专注可能非常强烈，以至于阻碍了你思考其他任何事情的能力。当你缺少的东西是时间时会发生什么？当你太忙了，感觉连呼吸的时间都没有。让我告诉你一个叫凯蒂的年轻女人的故事。她要求我们使用她的中间名，原因一会儿就会清楚。从她记事起，凯蒂就很有动力，非常有动力。我在高中的时候，我决心成为
valedictorian, so I took a sophomore level honors biology course as a freshman in high school and I studied around the clock. I had note cards. I walked through the hallways with the note cards if there was a holiday party. I brought the note cards and I had also studied till two or three in the morning. Katie says she wanted to be perfect at school. She eventually got to medical school where she excelled. She graduated at the top of her class and quickly started her residency. The new schedule was grueling. You can get in at 5.30 or 6 in the morning and you round on all your patients and then you round with the team. That means you go to all the patients and check in on their plan and adjust medications, etc. as necessary. And then there's usually
毕业生代表，所以我高一的时候就修了高二水平的荣誉生物课，我没日没夜地学习。我有笔记卡。我拿着笔记卡走在走廊里，如果有节日聚会，我带着笔记卡，而且我学习到凌晨两三点。凯蒂说她想在学校里做到完美。她最终进入了医学院，在那里表现优异。她以班级第一名的成绩毕业，并很快开始了住院医师实习。新的时间表非常折磨人。你早上5点半或6点进去，查房所有的病人，然后和团队一起查房。这意味着你去所有的病人那里检查他们的计划并根据需要调整药物等。然后通常有
a lunch conference where we have education and then in the afternoon we might take new patients in and keep following up on our patients. And on some days we get to leave at 4 p.m. some days we don't leave till 1 a.m. So and then you usually start the next day at 5.30 or 6 in the morning again. And you get one day off a week. Usually work 80 hours is a week. As Katie's workload grew she started to feel she couldn't afford to waste a single moment. Instead of spending any time relaxing she started to focus only on things directly related to her success at work. When I first
一个午餐会议，我们有教育活动，下午我们可能会接收新病人并继续跟进我们的病人。有些日子我们下午4点就能走，有些日子我们直到凌晨1点才走。所以，然后你通常在第二天早上5点半或6点又开始。你每周有一天假。通常每周工作80小时。随着凯蒂的工作量增加，她开始觉得她浪费不起哪怕一刻钟。她没有花任何时间放松，而是开始只关注与她在工作中成功直接相关的事情。当我刚
started it was just like really busy so I try to come home and I felt like you know I just don't have a lot of hours, so I need to make the most of them. And I was like, okay, I need to make sure I'm exercising, keeping my body healthy, and I need to read and stay on top of things. So I'd come home after a pretty long day, and I might go walking for half an hour, and then I'd read, and then I'd go to sleep. But then as the time went on, I decided to try to get in more exercise because I'm like,
开始的时候，真的非常忙，所以我试着回家，我觉得你知道我没有很多时间，所以我需要充分利用它们。我想，好吧，我需要确保我在锻炼，保持身体健康，我需要阅读并保持领先。所以我会在漫长的一天后回家，可能会去散步半小时，然后阅读，然后睡觉。但随着时间的推移，我决定尝试进行更多的锻炼，因为我想，
I never know when I'll get enough exercise in. So I started spending all my free daylight hours walking or running outside or going to the gym up to three hours a day, plus like working 15 hour days and then trying to read and then go to sleep. As she focused intensely on the things she believed were key to her professional success, Katie lost sight of things on the periphery. She didn't know it, but she was entering the tunnel of scarcity.
我永远不知道什么时候能有足够的锻炼时间。所以我开始把所有空闲的白天时间都花在外面散步、跑步或去健身房，每天最多三个小时，加上工作15个小时，然后试着阅读，然后去睡觉。当她专注于她认为对职业成功至关重要的事物时，凯蒂忽略了外围的事情。她不知道，但她正在进入稀缺的隧道。
In her case, it was scarcity brought on by a lack of time. So I wasn't going to the grocery store. My house wasn't unpacked yet and it was stressing me out and it was just a mess and I My clothes piled up. I had a lot of dirty clothes and Coming home just felt so overwhelming. I didn't want to be there And that's part of I think why I was walking so much just to get out of the house and get away from all the things I hadn't done
在她的案例中，这是由缺乏时间引起的稀缺。所以我没去杂货店。我的房子还没拆包，这让我压力很大，简直是一团糟，我的衣服堆积如山。我有很多脏衣服，回家感觉太不知所措了。我不想待在那里，我想这就是我为什么走那么多路的部分原因，只是为了离开家，远离所有我还没做的事情。
And I also forgot to pay a bill in the mix of all of this What did you forget to do what build did you forget to pay? It was my energy bill the old Katie would have spotted all of this I mean you would just basically at this point almost falling apart. It sounds like I Was I was falling apart There was something else. Katie had battled anorexia as a teenager. She knew she had to stay vigilant about her eating.
而且在这一切中，我还忘了付账单。你忘了做什么？你忘了付什么账单？是我的能源账单。以前的凯蒂会发现这一切，我的意思是，你基本上在这一点上几乎崩溃了。听起来我当时确实在崩溃。还有别的事。凯蒂十几岁时曾与厌食症作斗争。她知道她必须保持警惕。
But as she started to focus ever more intensely on work, she slipped back into some old habits. I was eating mostly vegetables and fruits, and I wasn't eating a whole lot else, maybe a cliff bar here and there. Despite all her medical training, Katie stopped taking care of herself. Here's one thing I haven't told you yet about scarcity. It can rob you of insight, insight about how your own mind is changing.
但当她开始更加专注于工作时，她又滑回了一些旧习惯。我主要吃蔬菜和水果，没吃太多其他东西，可能偶尔吃个能量棒。尽管受过所有的医学训练，凯蒂还是停止了照顾自己。关于稀缺，我还没告诉你一件事。它会剥夺你的洞察力，关于你自己的思想如何变化的洞察力。
Katie had no awareness that she was heading down a dangerous path. It became obvious to her only when it finally affected her work. I started to notice that I was like nearly missing things. As I was reviewing, for example, I admitted a diabetic and I almost didn't order insulin for them, but I did order the insulin. But I was like, I don't think I can keep up with this anymore, because if you don't give a diabetic insulin, especially if they're type one, they can have very fatal circumstances in the hospital and get really high blood sugars that can cause them to have an acidosis
凯蒂完全没有意识到她正在走上一条危险的道路。直到它最终影响到她的工作，她才意识到。我开始注意到我几乎漏掉了事情。例如，当我复查时，我收治了一名糖尿病患者，我差点没给他们开胰岛素，但我确实开了。但我当时想，我想我再也跟不上了，因为如果你不给糖尿病患者胰岛素，特别是如果他们是1型，他们在医院里可能会有非常致命的情况，血糖变得非常高，导致他们酸中毒，
and end up on a ventilator. So I turned myself in at the point that I saw that it was starting to affect my work. In two months of the residency program, Katie's body and mind had withered. Things had gotten so bad she had to go to a residential treatment center. Katie struggled with two things. Her body was desperately in need of nutrition. And her mind, she had to find a way to stop the intrusive thoughts that were consuming her.
最终需要上呼吸机。所以当看到它开始影响我的工作时，我自首了。在住院医师项目的两个月里，凯蒂的身体和思想都枯萎了。事情变得如此糟糕，以至于她不得不去一家住院治疗中心。凯蒂在两件事上挣扎。她的身体迫切需要营养。而她的思想，她必须找到一种方法来停止那些消耗她的侵入性想法。
She had to… Learn how to just sit, because we weren't allowed to exercise, we weren't allowed to stand, we weren't even allowed to do jumping jacks or squats, we had to just sit. Katie's mind was filled with angry and impatient thoughts. At first I felt like I felt useless because I thought, you know, if I'm not doing something productive, what is my purpose in life? But gradually, as the program literally forced her to do nothing, Katie started to emerge from the tunnel.
她必须……学习如何只是坐着，因为我们不允许锻炼，不允许站着，甚至不允许做开合跳或深蹲，我们必须只是坐着。凯蒂的脑子里充满了愤怒和不耐烦的想法。起初我觉得自己没用，因为我想，你知道，如果我不做点有成效的事，我的人生目标是什么？但逐渐地，当项目强迫她什么都不做时，凯蒂开始走出隧道。
She realized she had been so narrowly, relentlessly focused on one goal, doing well at work, that she'd ignored the very thing she needed to succeed, moments of relaxation, like watching TV, or in her case, painting. Kitty had loved art as a child, but she had put it aside because she thought it wouldn't help her become a better doctor. I'm kind of the type of person that just likes to study and then do after I've like mastered it from a studies point of view. And so to just do something without instruction is it feels very vulnerable to me. But it ended up kind of being my saving grace in my recovery. And I've actually created an art room in my house. I changed my office from a work room into an
她意识到她一直如此狭隘、无情地专注于一个目标，即在工作中表现出色，以至于她忽略了她成功所必需的东西，放松的时刻，比如看电视，或者在她的案例中，画画。凯蒂小时候很喜欢艺术，但她把它放在一边，因为她认为这不会帮助她成为一名更好的医生。我属于那种喜欢学习，然后在从学习的角度掌握它之后再去做的人。所以只是在没有指导的情况下做某事，对我来说感觉非常脆弱。但这最终成为了我康复过程中的救命稻草。我实际上在家里创造了一个艺术室。我把我的办公室从工作间改成了
art room. And it has paints and watercolors and chalks and everything you can imagine and I try to go in there once a week and just create something without any expectation just for the purpose of creating it because I can. Kitty eventually returned to her residency program with a new outlook. She started doing something that Eldar and Sender recommend to all busy people. She actually pencils time into our schedule to do nothing. One of the big things I've done is I kind of have a date night with myself once or twice a week, where I just schedule off the night, and I won't do anything with anyone else. And they'll just be free for me to do what I feel like.
艺术室。里面有颜料、水彩、粉笔和你能想象到的一切，我试着每周进去一次，不带任何期望地创作点什么，只是为了创作的目的，因为我可以。凯蒂最终带着新的视角回到了她的住院医师项目。她开始做埃尔达和桑德尔推荐给所有忙碌之人的事情。她实际上在日程表中预留了什么都不做的时间。我做的一件大事是，我每周或两周和自己约会一次，我只是把那个晚上空出来，我不和任何人做任何事。它们只是留给我做我想做的事。
It might be watching a movie. It might be taking a soak in the tub and reading a book, or being in my art room and painting whatever comes to me. But I do, like, I prioritize that and I actually won't accept plans with friends generally when I do this, so that's one of the things I do. Katie is consciously freeing up bandwidth, and something strange has happened as she's done so. The less consumed she feels about work, the better she does at work.
可能是看电影。可能是泡个澡读本书，或者在我的艺术室里画任何出现在我脑海里的东西。但我确实，我优先考虑这一点，而且我通常不会在我做这件事时接受朋友的计划，所以这是我做的事情之一。凯蒂正在有意识地释放带宽，当她这样做时，发生了一些奇怪的事情。她对工作感觉越不被消耗，她在工作中的表现就越好。
Honestly, it's kind of incredible, but at work, my brain has increased its capacity for fold. I am able to hold so many more things in my consciousness at once and manage them. I've just seen a really huge improvement in my ability to enjoy being in the company of others, to enjoy like occasions and to enjoy my work and do well at my work. While the psychological studies into scarcity and bandwidth are relatively new, the ideas are actually ancient.
老实说，这简直不可思议，但在工作中，我的大脑容量增加了四倍。我能够同时在意识中容纳更多的事情并管理它们。我看到自己在享受与他人相处、享受场合以及享受工作并在工作中表现出色的能力方面有了巨大的提高。虽然关于稀缺和带宽的心理学研究相对较新，但这些想法实际上很古老。
Avoid tunnel vision, keep difficult things in one part of your life from contaminating everything else. Be present. Say you have a big deadline tomorrow for something you've got to finish. You go home and you're spending the evening with your kids. And in that moment, you're not present-focused at all. What you're focused on is that deadline.
避免隧道视野，把你生活中困难的事情与其它部分隔离开来。活在当下。假设你明天有一个必须完成的大项目的最后期限。你回家了，和孩子们度过晚上。在那一刻，你根本没有专注于当下。你专注于那个最后期限。
You may go through minutes where you didn't hear what your kids were saying to you because your mind keeps going to this other thing. Tana vision is not in itself a good thing or a bad thing. Shutting out distractions can be helpful at times. The question is, do you know when you're inside the tunnel? To me, that's exactly the heart of managing scarcity. It's recognizing when are you trying to do something related to your scarcity or you really want to use that instinct and when have you made a conscious decision to do something else where what you really need to do is to not have
你可能会经历几分钟，你没听到孩子们在对你说什么，因为你的大脑一直在想别的事情。隧道视野本身并不是一件好事或坏事。屏蔽干扰有时是有帮助的。问题是，你知道你什么时候在隧道里吗？对我来说，这正是管理稀缺的核心。它是识别你什么时候在做与你的稀缺相关的事情，或者你真的想利用那种本能，以及什么时候你做出了有意识的决定去做别的事情，而你真正需要做的是不要让
it intrude on that something else. You're at home, you're with your kids, you chose to be a parent for that three-hour period. You really don't want scarcity to intrude then. Of course, it's easy to say, build free time into your schedule. Stay present with your family. Take a vacation. These strategies presume you have choices. You can't say, I've had it with being lonely. I'm going to take a vacation from being lonely. It's not a choice. And to me, loneliness and poverty are the forms of scarcity that feel the biggest because while all these forces are at play, there's no release valve, there's no escape mechanism.
它侵入到那别的事情中。你在家，你和孩子们在一起，你选择了在那三个小时里做一个家长。你真的不想让稀缺在那时侵入。当然，说起来容易，在你的日程表中建立空闲时间。与家人保持在一起。去度假。这些策略假设你有选择。你不能说，我受够了孤独。我要从孤独中休个假。这不是一个选择。对我来说，孤独和贫困是感觉最强烈的稀缺形式，因为当所有这些力量在起作用时，没有释放阀，没有逃生机制。
Elder and Sendo, one policy makers to design solutions that recognize how scarcity creates traps from which many people may not be able to extricate themselves. And they want the rest of us to stop preaching to those in poverty. If you look at programs at poverty, we often confound a little bit the attempts to help the poor with the attempts to educate them. Make sure that they show up in time, that they do the right things. From the perspective, we're taking with scarcity in some sense, if I'm very busy juggling a very complicated life, insisting that I show up at the office at 8 and not 805, is not doing me a favor, I don't need to be educated, it's just hard
埃尔达和森迪尔是政策制定者，他们设计的解决方案旨在认识到稀缺性是如何制造出许多人无法摆脱的陷阱的。他们希望我们其他人停止对贫困人口说教。如果你审视那些针对贫困的项目，我们往往会把帮助穷人的尝试与教育他们的尝试混为一谈。确保他们准时出现，确保他们做正确的事。从我们对稀缺性的理解来看，在某种意义上，如果我正忙于应付复杂的生活，坚持要求我在8点而不是8点05分出现在办公室，这对我并没有什么帮助，我不需要被教育，这只是很难
to manage. I'm, you know, the transportation is not reliable, my kid is not ready, I don't have a babysitter, I'm going to make mistakes that it's not clear educating me in quotes about them is going to help me at all, just makes my life all the more complicated. When people in poverty fail or make mistakes, the researchers think we should respond to them the same way we respond to mistakes made by airline pilots. There was a time not long ago when we thought that airline pilots who made mistakes were just bad pilots.
去管理。你知道，交通不可靠，孩子还没准备好，我没有保姆，我会犯错，而所谓的“教育”我并不能帮到我什么，只会让我的生活更加复杂。当贫困中的人们失败或犯错时，研究人员认为我们应该像对待飞行员犯错那样对待他们。不久前，我们还认为犯错的飞行员只是糟糕的飞行员。
Sandal says a big reason air travel has become safer in recent decades is that there has been a shift in thinking about such mistakes. Designers have made cockpits fault tolerant. Rather than trying to find perfect pilots, cockpits are now designed to account for human error. The goal is to alert pilots when they've made a mistake, and to diminish the consequences of mistakes. It's ironic that when we design cockpits, the entire mantra of fault tolerance seems so intuitive,
森迪尔说，航空旅行在近几十年来变得更加安全的一个重要原因是，人们对这类错误的看法发生了转变。设计师们让驾驶舱具备了容错能力。与其试图寻找完美的飞行员，现在的驾驶舱设计考虑到了人为错误。目标是在飞行员犯错时提醒他们，并减少错误的后果。具有讽刺意味的是，当我们设计驾驶舱时，容错的整个准则似乎是如此直观，
but when we design social policies, nobody's out there talking about, let's make this fault tolerant. I mean, you know, poor people have a lot on their mind, they're bandwidth is tax, they're gonna make mistakes. Let's make sure this program is robust when they do make that mistake. It's just not the way we think.
但当我们设计社会政策时，没有人谈论“让我们让它具备容错能力”。我的意思是，你知道，穷人有很多心事，他们的带宽被占用，他们会犯错。让我们确保这个项目在他们犯错时依然稳健。这根本不是我们的思维方式。
If I offer a training program, I don't sit there and say, let me make sure, you know what's gonna happen? This is for low income individuals. Surely they're gonna miss a few days because, you know, it's hard to get to class sometimes or other things around their mind. So let me design this curriculum so that it's in attendance tolerant.
如果我提供一个培训项目，我不会坐在那里说，让我确保，你知道会发生什么吗？这是针对低收入个人的。他们肯定会缺席几天，因为你知道，有时很难去上课，或者他们还有其他心事。所以让我设计这个课程，使其具有出勤容错性。
So even if somebody misses three days in a row, they'll be able to come on that fourth day and still feel caught up. In fact, a training curriculum is often quite the opposite. If you miss three days in a row, it's an invitation to miss the fourth day. You're not gonna get anything. Randy Drew eventually turned her life around. She found a low-income assistance program that offered her help. She walked with a financial counselor who gave her strategies for budgeting her money and keeping track of long-term priorities. I actually have a calendar now that I write down everything to make sure I'm paying things on the correct day and time.
这样即使有人连续三天缺席，他们也能在第四天来上课，并且仍然感觉跟得上进度。事实上，培训课程往往恰恰相反。如果你连续缺席三天，这简直就是邀请你缺席第四天。你什么也学不到。布兰迪·德鲁最终改变了她的生活。她找到了一个为她提供帮助的低收入援助项目。她与一位财务顾问合作，对方为她提供了预算管理和跟踪长期优先事项的策略。我现在确实有一个日历，我把所有事情都写下来，以确保我在正确的日期和时间支付账单。
It's taken time and little steps, but Brandy is no longer in the scarcity tunnel. She's been working for two years now, and she has savings. I know that if anything happens, God forbid if I lose this job, I know that I can survive for at least six months if I have to look for another. Eldor and Sendo themselves say they are constantly trying to keep the lessons of scarcity
这花了一些时间和一小步一小步的努力，但布兰迪不再处于稀缺性的隧道中。她已经工作了两年，并且有了积蓄。我知道如果发生什么事，上帝保佑，如果我丢了这份工作，我知道如果我必须寻找下一份工作，我至少可以维持六个月。埃尔达和森迪尔自己也说，他们一直在努力将稀缺性的教训
front and center in their own lives. As a busy academic, Eldor has come up with a rule. When an invitation to an event two months down the road comes along, he asks himself whether he would attend the event if it were tomorrow. If the answer is no, he declines the invitation, because his life is not going to be any less hectic two months from now. Preserving bandwidth takes conscious effort. Most of us, Eldar included, are going to violate the Eldar rule.
放在他们自己生活的核心位置。作为一名忙碌的学者，埃尔达想出了一个规则。当收到两个月后的活动邀请时，他会问自己，如果活动是明天，他是否会参加。如果答案是否定的，他就拒绝邀请，因为两个月后他的生活并不会变得不那么忙碌。保持带宽需要有意识的努力。我们大多数人，包括埃尔达在内，都会违反“埃尔达规则”。
We'll say yes to new commitments when we don't have the time, or pull out a credit card when we can't afford it. In those moments, it's important to look up. To notice, we are inside a tunnel. This episode was produced by Jenny Schmidt and Maggie Penman. It was edited by Tara Boyle. We had original music this week from Ramteen Arabliwi. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Laura Quarell, Thomas Liu and Arthshah. Our unsung hero this week is Sung Kim. Sung is a senior director with the local initiative Support Coalition. This is a national group that supports financial opportunity centers around the country, including
我们会在没有时间的时候答应新的承诺，或者在负担不起的时候掏出信用卡。在那些时刻，抬头看看很重要。注意到我们正身处隧道之中。本集由珍妮·施密特和玛吉·彭曼制作。由塔拉·博伊尔编辑。本周的原创音乐来自拉姆廷·阿拉布里维。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、劳拉·夸雷尔、托马斯·刘和阿特沙。我们本周的无名英雄是成金。成金是地方倡议支持联盟的高级主管。这是一个支持全国各地金融机会中心的全国性组织，包括
the one in Detroit that helped Brandy Drew get back on her feet. Sung got us in touch with Brandy after making numerous calls and reaching out to friends, colleagues and counselors. Sometimes the people whose stories need telling can be hard to find. Song helped us to bridge that gap. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like this episode, please remember to share it with a friend. We're always looking for new people to discover Hidden Brain.
底特律那个帮助布兰迪·德鲁重新站起来的项目。成金在打了无数电话并联系了朋友、同事和顾问后，帮我们联系上了布兰迪。有时，那些需要讲述故事的人很难找到。成金帮助我们弥合了这一差距。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果你喜欢这一集，请记得与朋友分享。我们一直在寻找新的人来发现《隐藏的大脑》。
Next week, we continue our U2.0 series with an episode about the health benefits of being outdoors. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. PR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下周，我们将继续我们的U2.0系列，探讨户外活动对健康的益处。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。